[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push way
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to another episode of fight
night flashbacks i'm here with the
legend the ecuadorian man himself the
ecuadorian boogie man as they call him
or just i call him that it is cheeto
vera and he's the number five
bantamweight in the world but number one
in our hearts it's just a matter of time
for the chair brother it's coming it's
coming uh what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna look at three uh important
fights i'd say in your career you've had
20 of them in the ufc so we had a bunch
of pick from so we picked some of our
favorites and uh i don't pick them i
learned when you learn uh we're kicking
this off with your sugar sean o'malley
fight which was uh ufc 252 so how long
how long ago was that
two years two years ago maybe three yeah
and i've you know both guests have moved
on from this fight he has a huge fight
coming up uh uh against uh munoz who's a
savage you obviously fought rob fought
in the main event you're looking for a
huge fight which i think you're going to
get against uh yawn so you guys can
you know you work here and then you guys
are both kind of doing your own thing
right i don't like to go back and rehash
i know you're i'm not interested in the
rematch i don't think he is i don't
think you are
i just feel like
we both are going to keep winning and
eventually if we we can meet up at the
top but you know i'm looking after
nobody right now i'm looking ahead and
ahead is number one spot yes sir you
know if that happened in the future i'm
hoping yeah if he if he'd often have to
beat like emunos then give him another
guy so
let's say all goes how we think it's
going to go and you beat yawn and then
you fight the winner of tj al-germain
you beat him and you're the champ
you know sugar shawn he could do it in a
year if he flew through you know two or
three guys but i'd say he's two or three
away from where you're at right now
number five yeah i feel you there you
know and in mma dude
every year it's a roller coaster
you don't know who's going to get on the
top it happens with
wahabit who expect he was going to be a
world champion he said he become a world
champion them globber like this [ __ ]
thing is a roller coaster if you don't
if you don't buckle up you're going to
get your ass kicked so you better be
right what's great about the sport so
let's where are we taking this the first
round
so this is two years so we're in the
height of the pandemic there's nobody
really in the audience
brilliant palm is there so that's cool
um with sugar shawn game plan go into
this what are you thinking because
obviously good movement athletic kid
your hair is blonde there yeah i was
blonde with a viking car right there oh
fantastic for for us this fight was just
like
let him throw like like you know let him
come to you because he is he's a very
good counterpuncher so how you counter
if you don't get yeah he's a creative
counterpuncher is good movement uh did
the leg kick surprise yeah or his length
was there anything surprising to you in
this fight i felt like we were literally
almost same size in there like
he's taller than me but his torso is
bigger than mine so the legs are the
same the arms are literally almost the
same so
it was it was kind of like
it wasn't shocking for me to be in there
with him in there like
he got a spit but so did i so
yeah it seems to me and i we we didn't
ask suga on this fight we didn't play
this fight for obvious reasons but um
it seemed like the game plan going for
him was heavy on the leg kicks to try to
maybe take away your movement because
you both move a ton yeah and then he
kicked me too but in there like see how
i point like i was talking about like
what you want to take i was like you
talk a lot before the fight but i'm
gonna talk here and he was kind of
shocked because he was like [ __ ] this
guy is talking to me now what were you
saying though i was just telling him to
pick a side because he was moving side
to side ah so i said where you want to
go pick a side yeah and then everything
will kick i would like blink an eye or
something like that and you know he i i
believe him focusing there and i think
too one of your huge advantages are
you're just as good southpaw as you are
traditional so you know when you look at
rob font when you start switching i you
know i don't know if they're ready i
don't know if they do now moving forward
and patreon's gonna be ready for this
and tj or al germain is you you can go
southbound it creates major issues for
people i can i have and most people can
switch but they don't have the same
difference correct for me it's the same
like
i'm i'm on both sides as confident then
when they switch on me i switch with
them so then whatever they have planned
to do it's fun yeah it's crazy man i
like i think like the biggest thing is
when a guy switches from uh you know
orthodox to southpaw when they go south
ball if they're not traditional
southpaws their defense lacks usually
their offense is good but the defense
that's the kick that hurt him from
southpaw
then south park yeah see his leg is
going there yes he's not moving as much
yeah he's staying stationary and that's
the nerve when that nerve goes you're
screwed it's gone yeah but it's also
nerve correct it's mental if you calm
down it goes away
it happened to
everybody i get i go kick in the elbow
in one fight against a young lineker
my arm was dead for like 30 seconds but
i just chill i was like
move wait for it to come back
you gotta relax well you look at uh like
uh michael chandler if you saw him in in
bellator his same thing in a mass square
garden dude i'm the commentator on the
fight man it just [ __ ] happens it's also
a very strategic move it's not a lucky
move like people that go oh it's luck no
no you know how hard it is to land that
[ __ ] kick there's no luck it's just
like lending a clean punch to the jungle
getting the ko you're gonna get all so
lucky with that right well you see him
there when he goes i'm [ __ ] with him
there you see how i'm walking around
because most of it is like he's like
here most guy will jump him i was like i
don't need to do america oh that's a
nice psychic i can just calculate
i got all the time i got 15 minutes to
kick your ass i don't rush him because
when you rush is when you get hurt
correct i learned the hard way ben
rothfeld but he uh do you so you lay in
another big like but look at his
movement there because you can tell the
leg is i heard him from sao paulo salpa
i kick his other leg and now he's trying
to throw a big hand this too late now
oh ah look at you you got a swagger in
there man you've heard that though 20
fights deep look at these kid that kick
is not good
i guess that's why he don't take the
fight
the second fight they offered us to
fight when conor fought uh i believe
cowboy in july
and he went in silent mode
i think now too you know he moves around
a ton so i don't know if uh jason
pirello the game plan was focused on
those light kicks but i'm sure if you
guys did fight again
though clearly light kicks are an issue
for everybody yes like that's the
problem with people people think they
only have to defend their face every
single way that somebody hit you that
[ __ ] thing hurts you got no shingles
you're going full blast
so it's like
you people sometimes think they can take
a couple logs like no you can't dude
it's the same with your jaw you take
couple in your face you're going down
he's going nuts here and that that's
where his leg really it was compromised
with that first kick that he pointed out
which he wanted to sleep in this one oh
really oh he went i'll call he came back
you see he went out came back
and then i went to his corner and said
go and [ __ ] yourself
man that's the fighter in you i'll tell
you what's interesting is watching that
i
i thought it was like back and forth and
then he hurt his leg you know to like
stepping back but you can watching it
now there's no shade on sugar sean
watching out it's like oh no those were
calculated leg kicks it compromises like
his leg was screwed after those three
leg kicks you knocked them down and they
stopped the fight how many people
will
hear everything i hear in the last
couple years like
negative and i will go crazy against it
i never even talk about it like for me
this guy is nothing like i'm not i'm not
after
uh his recognition or his flashiness i
don't give two [ __ ] yeah like in this
in the last three years people ask me
why you think i'm like i don't think
nothing like he can die tomorrow it will
move my heart yeah i gotta be honest
watching i wouldn't worry about it
either if i was you i'd be like yeah
yeah i beat him yeah like i it was
it was it was it was just as cling and
then when i point i know where the kick
was
like
yeah you called it to a t i was like
right now
like that's bad and then the elbow is
what really does this one right here
right
boom he's out right there
he's definitely compromised there
but when he stop it he goes he arms will
lame he come back yeah re-watching i
mean that wasn't and he's holding his
knee it wasn't yeah i get your cheeto
right now he's like oh yeah see on my
leg oh [ __ ] the nerves on her
when that happened when he kicked me the
first time his ankle that's when he fell
and then after if i i heard he was
saying like oh my ankle things were too
timely well
yeah but it all started with your leg
kicks which compromised them yeah
because that left leg that he's trying
to push off of is compromised so the
right one has to you know try to
overcompensate he rolls his [ __ ]
ankle but then the ground and pound
there's no excuse for the ground and
pound i mean that was straight
he could close the guard but i do think
sugar shawn learned from that we're
gonna find out what he learned when he
fights pedro munoz guarantee pedo's not
an easy perry is a great fighter office
yes perry's a great fighter both are
good fighters yeah
i don't need to take away nothing from
nobody like
some people feel better by talking so
i'm like no you're good bro relax you
need to prove a point yep calm down
you're good yeah you let your fighting
do it dude i like the the cornrows here
i love him dude i miss him you miss your
long hair yeah a little bit really i
bring it back who did the cornrows your
wife or you went to no there's a south
central there's a lady
that works for the ufc she does to oh
really the whole car i didn't know that
so she came to my room on on the day of
the fight and killed it like in
thirty-five
man i love it
hard work dude this is uh ufc 268
against frankie edgar the legend
everyone's favorite fighter i had
so much [ __ ] pressure in this fight
you felt a lot of pressure because my
coach
would be a pen they lose three fights
against [ __ ] etiquette oh that's
right so everybody want me to kill elgin
i was like guys no and he don't put
pressure on you but i come fully feel it
i can feel he lost three times i was
like coach we're getting this
[ __ ] don't you worry about it
chill i got this man so going to this
fight especially you know big ufc
pay-per-view frankie edgar you know a
lot of pressure dude i wasn't i wasn't
fighting four rows
i i didn't feel the pressure in a way
like against me
dude
being in new york that week
i don't i felt high every day i was
[ __ ] living i wasn't about to go i
was so calm we were walking down the
street i was popping some mushrooms i
was like feeling [ __ ] great i was
like
i'm gonna make it big i didn't
i'm not mystic mac i didn't call the
runner the kick but i was like this is
going to be [ __ ] work felt good you
knew going into it
you look good it just i just everything
they already i can feel the [ __ ]
enemy i was like okay you're gonna be a
good [ __ ] we're breaking this we're
picking this up in what round mike the
third round
yeah man this had to kind of give you
validation that you're on the right path
right when you beat a guy like frankie
edgar a legend man i love frankie and
he's the first guest ever on food truck
oh really he's a new jersey ever that's
the only guy
that i fought in my 20 fights that when
i was a kid i root for him so hard yeah
but he was a [ __ ] 55er
aldo was a 45er 45 and 35
i'm not friends with them on the [ __ ]
you maybe we cross paths yeah but elgar
was a 55 when i was a kid so i was like
i used to [ __ ] root for him like a
[ __ ] i never went till now yeah
yeah he did his footwork and then his uh
head coach mark henry that's his secret
weapon and i worked with mark henry dude
he is really good at trying
frankie edgar uh you know just monsters
barboza like he works with all those
sounds he had a good team on at one
point on live like he have like all
those good and they all kind of strike
very well yep so it's the third round
you're doing work here what's up guys
let's take a little break from chatting
with my boy cheetah vera on some of his
amazing fights 20 fights in the ufc
it's important that he keeps winning but
you know what's even more important
talking about grooming man you got them
bushes down there and listen all men
strive for gold like my boy cheeto gold
medals gold watches gold belts gold
everything however there's a certain
type of bro who goes the extra mile he
walks with confidence of an eagle and
giggles in the face of danger he's a big
hairless winning machine and when he
unzips his pants he sees
platinum that's right kids platinum
that's right manscape would like to
introduce you to their best biggest
ultimate hygiene bundle yet the platinum
package 4.0 manscaped is the leader in
below the waist grooming now trust them
with the whole shebang join the 4
million bros worldwide who trust
manscape by going to manscape.com for 20
off and free shipping with the code
shob20 with shop20 what do you get well
manscape's brand new platinum package
4.0 like i said their biggest bundle
ever and they're giving you a huge
manly discount the manscape platinum
package 4.0 is the one stop shop for the
man who deserves it all they designed
this package to allow you to fully align
your entire hygiene routine with elite
products we're talking about the best of
the best only in the platinum package
what will you find i'm glad you asked
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed
whacker air nose trimmer you get the
ultra premium body wash ultra premium
two in one shampoo conditioner ultra
premium deodorant the crop preserver
anti chafing ball deodorant crop reviver
ball spray toner the anti chafing boxers
some of my faves the shed travel bag to
hold all your goodies while you're
traveling all right again the lawn mower
4.0 the body trimmer the weed whacker
nose and air hair trimmer it's fantastic
they're both waterproof so you can shave
with less mess you just do it in your
shower man super easy comes with a
little light on it so if you're doing
the dark if you're weirdo do in the dark
all right
manscape got you covered man get 20 off
and free shipping with the code shop20
at manscape.com that's 20 off the
platinum package with free shipping at
manscape.com use the code shop20 it's
time you enjoyed the finer things in
life get yourself a platinum package for
your platinum package that's
manscape.com20 all right 20 off with
free shipping at manscape.com use the
code shop20 sch aub20
so you're going into the third you give
him the finger
and the ref slapped your finger he can
do that he can
i should sue the [ __ ] for a hair
in my head yeah you could in this
culture
you know what happened here
the end of the second round you know
we're like on a hard fight
so the round stops and we both look at
each other kind of like ming mugging us
almost like is it a respect thing though
or what what's going on
it was kind of like a [ __ ] you kind of
like what's up what's up my mirror
you're right bob's still here oh that
elbow dude that thing was cool
the opera that would take his head away
but [ __ ] it so when we the round was
over we kind of like bombed chess like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and then he'll give me
a look so i told i told myself if i walk
away from that look his dog is gonna
he's gonna be like oh he's [ __ ] i got
him he's a little scared i won't [ __ ]
you just you still let him know
[ __ ] i'm here the ref didn't
like that yeah but from new york you
know they're probably friends yeah yeah
they get points yeah he's a laying out
there so
listen i've never met anybody who
doesn't like frankie i like never in my
life but i didn't like him look at you
savage
ring ring
you're just
thriving in this chaos i do believe i
was a viking one day yeah i guess
ecuadorian viking yeah yeah i don't know
nor a pirate i think but that too or
maybe both maybe mom pirate that viking
they have a kid and it came out
and here here go on the third same thing
pressure
obviously you're hoping he slows down i
knew i knew right here right here i knew
you didn't finish him you lost the fight
i i just put up a lot of people even
going into this third round
night you're seeing on the screen yeah
1919 1919 i used to have it that way i
just i always put myself against the
wall just to get extra out of me meaning
you you always have in your mind that
you're down two rounds in this fight
specifically it was new york he got a
couple takedowns i got the damage but i
was like hey i'm losing this fight i
gotta kill this [ __ ] if i'm not
gonna win and i also going into this
fight i told myself i don't beat this
guy i will never make it yeah that's the
thing you know because frankie still you
know has a lot of fight in him he's a
lot of dog in him he's a legend you lose
to frank
to me this is the ufc going all right
let's see what cheetos made of like
let's see if we can bank on cheeto you
know these differences
take down son
but like i told myself i don't win this
fight i'm gonna be a [ __ ] regular guy
i i like putting that present to myself
i'm i'm okay with that
i agree i had a fight with gabriel
gonzaga remember walking on all right if
i and it was my
third fight in ufc i went if i can't
beat gabriel gonzaga i'm gonna retire
because if i can't beat him then i'm
just a guy i'm never gonna be fighting
the big fights i'm out of here man it's
not worth it
they're starting fighting a career where
the ufc throws you and goes all right
let's see let's see if he can get past
this because the fight with aldo was
close whatever but i thought that five
should be a five rounder anyway but this
one was like
okay this is your your second chance you
don't get this [ __ ] you
agree yeah if you lose the aldo use the
frankie then you'll see my great work
just keeping it real you got to keep it
real and in this game you can be like oh
yeah i'm kind of good no you got to be
you're going to be a dick and you're
going to be addicted to yourself too hey
you know when this your [ __ ] sock
dick i was like okay cool i gotta go win
this yeah and you're just playing
pressure and freight but again frankie
has so much fighting him man
his combos and a lot of it's
were you feeling the body shots because
a lot you know a lot of mark henry's
stuff is body shots setting up to the
body go to the head i
i have a good stomach then yeah i think
the core comes from running from doing
sit-ups every damn day after practice
and you're just staying in shape like
the longer you are in shape you don't
two minutes on the third round look at
you go forward man it's such an asset
for your cardio man how hard you work
and you're starting to lay in two on
them
and it's like why like i always tell
myself if i'm not injured
why stop
yes
why stay home
why been drinking all like every weekend
while eat [ __ ] every time like i just
can't do it that was a nice scramble
that was a great scramble because again
he
if he controls you down there you
probably lose this fight brother because
that you know you're in new york he's a
jersey kid that take down the dominant
round you know it's close first fight
there wasn't
a way i wouldn't by decision even if i
khabib him for three runs take him down
and hold he famous he's too famous too
he's too beloved he it's you know it's
in freaking new york son you know this
fight
look in my last fight
o'malley was supposed to fight here
oh that's right hunter cabo
hey chito there's no fight for you right
now dominic don't want to do it i don't
want to bring dominion back but this is
a real talk dominic is not available
you will have to fight somebody out of
the ranks because
frankie we're giving it to miley and in
honestly you already had aldo now we're
giving him a chance i'm like hey
i like that you talking me like a man
honest
i'm face to face i'm sure i'm like oh
good man
that's why i like him i'm like i take
that it's all good i will wait
two weeks later o'malley go on twitter
oh i don't want to find new york too
much tax it's my coach have a grab a
grappling tournament i was like this
sounds very weak
that sounds like you're a boy in the
fight yes i call hunter
you see that tweet give me that fight
right now what do you say he's yours boy
damn i appreciate your business i'm like
i appreciate your front kick to the face
y'all must have forgot because we're all
hot on chandler versus tony ferguson
this is not so smart
dude
that's off to the right like you finish
a guy like this man and frank yeager
with a front kick like that
of course you you know you're going to
be in those main events you mean the big
fights how happy was jason perella
we drink whisk until we die that night
love it
dain in the bible [ __ ] zac efron with
the mustache
are you doing haunted right there all
right what are you talking you're
talking to dc rogan in them i'm just
telling him i'm coming
that's all right i did it right a little
better than wrestling i was talking [ __ ]
to
to dc but i was making wrestling jokes
john what a fight and then here this is
our last one this is your most recent
fight it's rob font who's number five in
the world and here's my issue with the
rankings so rob frank font was number
five
at the very minimum i'm giving you uh
two ten eight rounds
we could argue even more than that but
two ten eight rounds and he's number
five so for me you go eight to five if
you dominate a guy like that you're
telling me it should only be five maybe
a little more yeah like before can we
get four yeah if you dominate number
five this wasn't even a fight bro he had
a lot of output but look at his face oh
he dude he was messed up he's
one of his eyes was fully shut down his
that car they gave him with that elbow
duty was [ __ ] deep oh that elbow was
nasty and what round is this mike
this is the fifth round now you and i
i'm sure perello didn't say this but i
feel look at he's such a dog dude he's
still in there i just every time i make
eye contact i'm like [ __ ] you dude yeah
you're not giving me an inch dude and
then i started laughing because i was
like you want it you get it yeah i mean
just look at his face again he you know
this fight is one of the you know fights
of the years for having a conversation
right there
yeah there's not really a mark on your
face no
he had so much output but not a lot of
and he has he does have power you know
but nothing i feel his power came from
cutting
so much weight like he's just a bigger
he's a 45 or fighting a 35 yeah like i
feel
if i'm an idiot i could go to 25 and
have an easy road like just because i
went 153 right now if i have something
really but i'm like i don't need that
i'm not we're going to kill yourself i'm
not a white carter [ __ ] that oh come on
let's do it look at you dude
energy is from dominating come on time
it's time
i don't get paid by saying sitting down
come on
yeah poor rob fund he's too tough for
his own good man yeah such a beast the
corner [ __ ] up that's a terrible i
think they should turn into oh they
should throw it on the floor they're not
not that that's not
to be cocky just
[ __ ]
wouldn't throw the towel for me i know
that yeah i would tell my coaches
throwing the towel
see he's just such he's too tough for
his own good because he's still
trying to hang in there
he have
one minute on every round of good pop
after that he was just
well i think a lot of that is you know
you look at the jumping knee the
spinning back like you're hitting him
with these shots man where it's it's
damn near impossible to [ __ ] you know
to bounce back from like it's taking the
win out of his sails yeah but again he's
too tough for his own good in his corner
you know they just let him do his thing
boom boom
you're south paul here
yeah he really struggled when you went
south paul but just his output dude it's
so nuts to me he throws five punches
there but no one of those things
but again to the point of bad judging if
you're a judge like man he's really
bringing it you're like no dude none of
that's landing you can tell like you
look at your defense
and you're landing
you're more precise you know he has a
higher output but yours is more precise
which if i'm a judge i'd give that more
credit than anything
no you're right they're like the the the
judges today are [ __ ]
go [ __ ] you can put you put like a bag
of [ __ ] on the seat and we'll give a
better score yeah
yeah a bag of [ __ ] would give you 3 10
8. oh yeah
you're gonna open a little bit you can
breathe but
yeah i feel i feel like you like you
know you're so up on the cards here and
you know he's certain he's coming but
he's not landing a ton you know
god damn
i mean you boys are throwing this is the
fifth round look at this pace dude
did this give you confidence to go five
rounds oh
i honestly like there was a point that i
i i feel like probably want me to finish
and i wanted to finish it but i was like
let's just let's just fight use the
defense use some tools and now that i'm
back in the gym i'm like okay this
worked this wasn't good because like
the defense was [ __ ] amazing and he
i don't get this overnight this is every
day on the gym that was a good front
kick yeah this is dedication he's just
everyday like you've earned this you can
and after this fight i didn't use this
as like okay i'm cool
on thursday i was in the gym really oh
yeah i was like coach what's up uh
you're prosperous what you want to do is
like [ __ ] you told me what to do i'm
just a [ __ ]
i'm a horse you put the [ __ ] rope and
tell me where to go and his per is
perello said hey let's chill out let's
take a little easy i took that week off
because i got covered so i was forced to
take the week off i couldn't win a run
so on the the monday after the week off
i went back to the gym and we went back
to job cross yep course basics just
now cause you're also out look at you
putting you tell you you're also talking
about you know rob font fans himself a
box he's a damn good boxer man and
you're sitting right in there
outstriking the guy this has to give you
confidence going into the peter yan
fight he's also
pressure forward guy
heavy on the boxing relies heavy on
boxing
i'm a nozzle yeah yeah you're not
actually you're a showman but you but
here's my thing right i don't tell you
is disrespect you've also earned it he's
also higher ranked than you he was also
favorited going into the fight
so for you going into this fight doing
what you did at this level it's like
you've earned that you can do that stick
your tongue out and do that [ __ ] you
know yeah you're not just doing it but
you're doing the work yeah you're right
all those voices
too
what shorts are you wearing dude uh
yellow shirts and inside reds i like the
colors for ecuador what else yeah on new
york i did italy because of my italian
passport and there's a lot of italians
in new york italian passport oh yeah new
zealand passport [ __ ] yeah pasta my
grandma baby your grandma's italian yeah
i didn't know that god is my uncle oh
[ __ ] oh satisfied boom boom
dude my finger i don't know how it got
caught dude my hand was bleeding like a
[ __ ] from what i have no idea i
have i have a deep cut
this might seem like my hand is how my
glove is shining
i think it looks like a pound of blood
from the finger
oh
yeah his face dude it looks like a scene
out of salt four it's just like brutal
looks like somebody's tapping a tomato
yeah it really does
oh that hurt him too yeah man and you've
heard him earlier in the fight with that
but see you what i love you're still not
going crazy man jason herzog's like yeah
rob fund's gonna have to die for me to
stop this
i think they're homies chicky chicky no
homie's not gonna look at you showman
one
i have poor rob i feel i feel i feel
jason giving the chance
of the dog because i i heard
somehow they know each other but i'm
like [ __ ] that's if if i know you i'm
gonna stop it in the fourth yeah he
didn't do many favors there
and that's the new england cartel tony
good job i'm sure yeah i wouldn't say
thank you for the fight i don't have any
problems no he you know he doesn't talk
[ __ ] he's just a hard-working dude yeah
meat and potatoes blue collar tough
[ __ ] guy man both of them him and
kate are tough yes hell yeah look at his
face dude
yeah it was a tough night in the office
you just for hit like obviously you're
fine look at you for god's sakes but for
him it's like you know there's certain
fights you watch and you're like oh
they're never gonna be the same and i
i'm not saying that's happened to rob
font but there are times but this could
be one of those could be there's a
challenge you look at jds stipe you look
at you know stipe uh francis you look at
some of tony ferguson's fights you know
we just gave you that's a good job
you look at the wars like god this is
not good dude some fights and it's not
worth it like
perilous stopped the fight when b.a
fought the second time against usp
he threw it out beat you [ __ ] never
give up but yeah was fighting on the
street when he was retired just because
he loved fighting yeah bj's a monster he
used like to fight and and against usp
he was taking too much damage throw a
towel
but that's what he's been around that's
what i'm saying i think jace parella who
doesn't get enough recognition i think
he's a coach that
uh you know he's one of the best in the
game and being part of the best coaches
in the world especially in the ufc part
of that part of your responsibility is
saving the fighter to live to fight
another day not it's not his that's not
font's night in the office it wasn't
happening man it doesn't matter it's not
happening so you guys got thrown the
towel so his next fight he can prepare
correctly and win the fight now it's
like [ __ ] you're emotional here i am
do your families in the crowd i got my
mom my dad
all my kids my wife so it was like at my
first main event too is my first [ __ ]
man event i had look with that record i
came to ufc at 6 00
i did my whole career in the ufc how
many people get caught after two losses
oh dude that's the thing you know the
the classic saying goes you don't want
to gain experience in the ufc you don't
get to the ufc i'm gonna be ready to go
you're the only guy i know who's done it
and has has made it this far in these
look at you and your wife man sometimes
i tell people honestly i'm gonna be
fully honest i have no [ __ ] idea how
i'm here right now yeah i get i work
hard i got a heart i got balls but
most people that made it with a small
record is no longer wrong no because
it's a marathon not a sprint and the
thing is if you're going to do you see
the experience it doesn't really work
that way because the the guys you're
getting have 30 fights 40 fights 30
fights they've seen everybody man you
know when you're you know you have what
you say six fights seven fights i was
six and one when i made it to ufc yeah i
had four fights dude so it's like you
don't want to get to the ufc when you
don't have the experience because like
ed soros says
if they call any of these guys nogueira
anderson silva machida when they call me
we say yes to everybody because if
you're not ready to take on all comers
when you see this ain't for you you're
not ready yet he goes i only sign guys
who can beat anybody from number from
the champ to the 50th guy if you can't
fight them and figure out a way to win
you shouldn't be in the ufc
it is true it's crazy like i remember my
first couple fights i was like
what i'm doing here yeah okay kick as
hard as you can okay try to attack them
but i was really using my talking to
myself like okay um let's do a job
across maybe
now i'm just i'm doing what the skills i
i i've been getting now with a good
coach and the last five years but
[ __ ] in 2014 i was just playing he's
just a dog you're a dog you know and it
is it's one of your biggest assets when
you can make that kind of mental that
dog mentality then you add experience
then you add you know your technique
dude
that's where you're number five in the
world and hope for your champ soon
perello definitely wants that pick
pretty bad
oh look you're a little girl man did
they like watching you fight or they get
scared uh my wife told me they were they
were watching yeah they were like
usually kind of like walking side to
side it's a lot going on it's a lot and
then there's and there you can feel the
energy in there
he's not a positive narrative the person
actually going rip his hat off you're
like that's my dad you know it's a lot
it's crazy it is crazy it's a [ __ ]
wild sport that's why you can treat this
like it's okay fighting is not okay [ __ ]
it if you're not willing to give a
thousand percent
every [ __ ] day you're in the wrong in
the wrong job yeah you can play
basketball you can play football you
can't play fighting and when people say
a sport i'm like no no he said he's not
[ __ ] different different this is a
[ __ ] fighting spirit somebody's gonna
die well you're pretty damn good at it
and thank god
in the world and you're soon gonna be
the champ man and we're rooting for you
here thanks for sitting down and going
over some of these fights and we you
have 20 fights dude so it's tough to
pick shout out to the thick boy staff
picking them we love you brother next
time we do this i'll be your champ
a good amount of money your champ next
time we do this we will i got to be the
first stop when you come champ though
deal easy deal you gotta wear the yeezys
love you man i will cheat over
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push break chains go hard kick ass take
names